I'm not gonna lie I think that it's time
for America to step his game up what's
going on hi I'm David and I'm
representing America hi I'm Blake and
I'm American
Pam me who I'm from Japan and today
we're gonna swap school lunches my
school lunches in Japan they're called
cue Shoku I loved it it was pretty good
school lunches as I'll remember I mean I
probably wouldn't like them as much now
as I did back then I would just eat like
four burgers every day or like eight
slices of pizza we had this thing when I
was really young called the cheese
zombie which was just like two giant
pieces of bread and a bunch of like
melted American cheese oh yeah I mean I
liked it I liked it we had this thing
called UFO which was literally a giant
goes up that was shaped like a UFO and
it had some meat and vegetables inside
that sounds way better
my favorite was I get pie we say it's a
bread it's Friday
tons of sugar our food has a lot of
sugar in it right oh maybe it's less
sugar less sugar right I would like to
see the stats on this let you just walk
lunches let's do it let's do it oh this
is the American lunch Wow we got a swab
now this is crazy
all yours looks way better that's salmon
that looks fantastic is that miso soup
oh that's crazy in a school lunch I'll
be excited to go to school so we have
carrots and ranch which I think that's
pretty standard the green beans is also
pretty standard apple slices we don't
necessarily get healthcare in the US but
we got apples this is like a manwich
sloppy joe we got this from the freezer
pride was cooked four days ago
cheeseburger
we got to tell you Taj you usually can't
mess up tater tots I'm excited meditated
hogs but I don't know what's going on
with this book
I mean it's not brioche and then you got
an S quick cuz you got to have your
chocolate milk that's if your mom didn't
give you money to go to the vending
machine get a coke you know what I mean
so I would really like to know what you
have on that tray though right
we soup corn soup it is definitely a
thing in Japan and you can even buy it
in vending machines during the winter
that's crazy I never seen a super
vending machine before pineapple salmon
there's some in their schools coming up
which is Japanese fried chicken some key
to key there is usually a vegetable and
we got milk I don't know about her but
I'm ready to swap she could take this
yeah I want to swap I didn't want to
stop then I can I better keep my salmon
yeah it's still frozen
burger burger that's not a sloppy job
the hamburgers deadbeat brother
don't try a bite of this I want to take
you from you you know that's your main
part I want you be able to finish that
that's pretty good I could eat this
every day this is great I wanted to find
out what kind of meat it was I took a
bite I still don't know it's probably
beef I don't think we could get a turkey
burger in like a US school lunch it
could be a be on no definitely you're
the salad is not that bad it tastes
better than it looks
okay it's probably the dressing probably
the dressing so what's all in this so
that doesn't look like a vegetable
there's one of the maybe YUM what is
this yeah good how like a bull bar yeah
so this is gonna be like so dope yeah
the dirty Road Oh No
sound of sweets I'm gonna say Japanese
lunch is a kick in American to the house
right now where is it tastes like I was
thinking it would be like a seaweed or
something but it tastes more like a
saute vegetable that I haven't had
before it's so good
well this is good Yuji I don't even know
what good is so now I know I got the
good one it's gonna make the taste
better so what you do is you dip the
carrot in the ranch
I'm not gonna lie this Japanese fried
chicken might give Kentucky a run for
his money so see also you see how she
went in with the fork an Americans not
going in with the fork we're going in
fingers just get in there
kind of interested to see what this corn
soup is talking about that's good yeah
the miso soup is amazing it just seems
like they take a lot more care right it
takes more time this is like a nice
light fulfilling lunch I'm gonna have to
say I guess I was just ignorant to the
fact that Japan had amazing school
lunches out of everything that I sampled
I'd say the corn soup the hijiki and
like a Japanese fried chicken was
amazing that was a good lunch that I
would make for myself on like a Saturday
if I had kids I would rather than be
eating that lunch
I still love Japanese lunch that was
like so much dedication it made me so
happy when I was kid yeah I am all about
the Japanese lunch definitely feels like
home although I do like tater tops
there you have it Japanese lunch with a
side of tater tots everybody's happy
[Music]